[Música]
muito boa tarde gente obrigado pelo
convite na suãã muito legal estar aqui
nesse ted fazendo algumas reflexões fiz
várias aqui assistindo as outras
palestras bom é vindo para uma faculdade
eu pensei o que me disseram quando eu
entrei na faculdade então em 1997
eu entrei na faculdade a palavra da moda
empreendedorismo eu saí da faculdade a
palavra continua na moda e nesse mesmo
ano de 97 um cara ganhou o apelido de
renato sorriso
o renato tinha até então uma das
profissões mais desprezadas da sociedade
eu e vocês provavelmente quando éramos
pequenos nessa gente não estudasse
falavam pra gente não vai estudar você
vai ver a galeria e renato ressignifica
ou a profissão de gari
naquele dia da semana que a gente joga
fora que a gente descarta né
na segunda-feira ele escolheu uma
segunda feira segunda feira de carnaval
dia que a cidade do rio de janeiro tem
um acúmulo de metro cúbicos de lixo por
dia por um gari trabalhar ele pediu para
trabalhar nesse dia e pediu pra sapucaí
e aí é em vez de levar uma ferramenta
incrível desenvolvida pelos gênios lado
e meti o pessoal do vale do silício
neowin com patins naqueles que vai
andando mais rápido pra bahia
ele só levou uma ferramenta aquela
ferramenta que todos nós podemos
carregar e que o único risco que a gente
tem quando a gente utiliza essa
ferramenta é contagiar as pessoas e
levou toda a felicidade que ele tinha
aquela oportunidade que é que a vida
tinha andado para ele que aquilo era tão
real e varrer com tanto entusiasmo
sambava ao mesmo tempo que além de tomar
bronca do chefe dele lá no clube ele
ganhou a admiração de todo mundo que
estava nessa época é uma festa popular
do mundo e no ano seguinte ele não pediu
e foi obrigado a ir para a sapucaí
três anos depois o renato já tinha uma
aula com mais 50 garis desfilando com
ele e ele e se transformou num símbolo
da festa popular do mundo ele
transformou esse uniforme laranja em
património imaterial da cidade do rio de
janeiro
o renato fez com que o concurso público
de gari fosse mais concorrido do
município do rio e que a empresa que ele
trabalha fosse uma das mais admiradas
nós cariocas o renato é um baita exemplo
de gari não
renato é um baita exemplo de sambista
não
o renato é um baita exemplo de
empreendedorismo isso empreendedores
desde 95 ele trabalha na mesma empresa
com a mesma carteira assinada na mesma
praça pública que ele trabalhava há 20
anos atrás
aqui na zona na zona norte do rio
renato foi o seu empresário professor
palestrante que ele também é de vez em
quando ele seria mais um ele é mais um
como gari ele o gari ele é um cara que
significou pra sempre uma profissão
ele fez da vida dele o melhor projeto
dele isso é empreendedorismo
desde que eu saí da faculdade busca
explicações para a palavra
empreendedorismo algumas vêem meio
estranhas meio-pesados né
a gente achou que empreender abrir um
negócio e aí é no dicionário a gente tem
mais de 20 nós só para o
empreendedorismo ea gente só tem dois
antônimos que só duas coisas não
significa o empreendedorismo acomodar
estacionar e é só isso que a gente
precisa saber lembrando que estacionar
não está parado e só estaciona quando o
movimento então o seu pára o carro numa
se encontra no seu site de carro
encontra uma vaga para a primeira vaga
geralmente muito longe do lugar que eu
encontro várias vagas melhores do que
aquelas como eu acho que sou muito
importante por universo eu acho que a
lei de murphy não é eu me acomodei o que
a gente faz com a vida da gente a gente
estaciona basicamente na primeira vaga
que a gente encontra para a vida da
gente é e porque a gente não consegue
pensar no exemplo do renato como
empreendedorismo porque a gente persegue
o sucesso
a gente era [ __ ] programado para termos
sucesso e quando eu faço essa pergunta
fez uma grande covardia uma das maiores
do país pedir pros jovens levantarem e
escreverem os casos de sucessos que esse
sucesso
o líder por exemplo o steve jobs caras
como steve jobs são associados ao
sucesso
é interessante porque eu me emocionei
muito na palestra da vovozinha que
estava aqui na voz dos 93 anos né é
engraçado porque em momento nenhum eu
falei sobre o sucesso profissional
mas a gente imagina o sucesso como
era como conta bancária como que a gente
fez profissionalmente na nossa vida não
existe o sucesso profissional que
justificar o fracasso familiar se para
você ter sucesso na sua vida você tem
que abrir mão das pessoas que estão
próximas a você você está caminhando no
sentido oposto o sucesso e se engana
quem acha que família são os filhos
maridos só nós que trabalhamos fora
passando em média os nossos filhos
acordados uma hora por dia faça um
exercício
muitas vezes a gente sai de casa alguns
de vocês estão montando esse evento
provavelmente saiu de casa deixar os
filhos dormindo e vão chegar em casa e
os filhos vão estar dormindo
é o que acontece por exemplo com a minha
esposa que é uma executiva ea gente tem
uma hora para transformar os nossos
filhos em seres humanos entre eles é
isso que nós pais fazemos com os nossos
filhos no pouco tempo que temos com ele
uma hora a transformá los em seres
humanos incríveis quando a gente chega
no nosso trabalho a nossa faculdade
a gente muitas vezes em oito horas lado
de alguém para transformar essas pessoas
em seres humanos incríveis
a gente tem muito mais chance de mudar o
mundo impactar a vida daquelas pessoas
que estão oito horas com agentes do que
os nossos próprios filhos dentro de casa
então se para você construir o seu case
de sucesso
quanto mais degrauzinho você subir menos
tempo você tiver as pessoas você tá
caminhando no sentido oposto o sucesso
ea felicidade entra nisso né quem já dei
um google escreveu o livro empreendendo
felicidade eu quero falar de caminho de
felicidade né
aí como é que a gente encontra a
felicidade lógica e não cada um encontra
sujeito que quiser eu também estou
procurando a minha
a única coisa que a gente precisa
entender é que a felicidade não é mais
uma opção a felicidade agora é uma
obrigação é uma estratégia de
sobrevivência ea gente precisa redefinir
os nossos conceitos de felicidade porque
o que a gente aprendeu sobre felicidade
é que a felicidade é algo material dos
nossos avós ensinaram é que felicidade é
algo a ser conquistado geralmente no fim
da vida quando a gente conseguia ter um
carro do ano a casa própria poupança e
aí sim quando o corpo já não estava
agüentando muita gente resolveu ser
feliz
e aí o mundo recebeu uma série de loucos
gerações complexas taxados de
complicadas desfocadas gerações perdidas
que inverter essa lógica que disseram
pra gente que a felicidade não era
material era experimental uma molecada
que disse
gente que não queria ter um relógio caro
no pulso nenhum carro aliás eles não
querem ter carro uma galera que disse
que não quer ter casa própria poupança
um crachá que diz que ele é diretor de
alguma coisa o dono de alguma coisa
uma geração que disse pra gente que
tinha só uma exigência pintar o cabelo
da cor que eles quisessem de opção
sexual que eles quisessem casar com que
eles quisessem quantas vezes quisesse
fazer o que eles entendessem da vida
deles não tinha muito problema se o pai
não sabia com a profissão que lhes é um
tempo porque daqui a 15 anos grande
parte das profissões já não vão mais
existir
esses jovens líderes com y z redefiniram
o conceito de felicidade a busca da
humanidade há milênios e provaram pra
gente pedir complicados de complexos
eles não têm nada
foram os dois melhores gerações que
habitaram o nosso planeta porque de fato
ensinaram pra gente que a felicidade
pode ser conquistado agora no momento
presente e se nós empresários não
fizemos nossos funcionários felizes eles
vão embora os maridos não fizerem suas
mulheres feliz
elas vão embora e ninguém é obrigado a
ficar casado com ninguém se a mulher
conhecia milar da agora não é com dois
filhos pequenos a sociedade não vai
colher que a minha família vai construir
uma família ninguém separa da família
nunca então eu sou o único homem da
família o mais novo de todos então fazer
tudo com ela vão correr atrás mas o
mundo não vai condenar a ela né não vai
perder em casa realmente negócio
familiar eu não gosto muito complicado
então essa geração que disse pra gente
que os filhos vão embora de casa pode
ser uma criança com 10 anos não vai
embora de casa fisicamente mas com dez
anos uma criança não quisermos perguntar
nada para o pai ela não pergunta ela vai
embora e emocionalmente daquele espaço
essa geração disse pra gente então que a
única coisa que eles querem é serem
felizes então a felicidade deixou de ser
uma opção e passou a ser uma estratégia
de sobrevivência ea liderança que até
então era associada à hierarquia ao
poder foi ressignificada para todos nós
a gente veio do mundo eu vejo o mundo
com 38 anos onde o professor sempre
saber mais que o aluno pais sem saber
mais o que o filho o chefe sempre saber
mais do estagiário ea gente acredita
a coisa mais importante porque existe na
vida da gente era o cargo de agente
ocupava o crachá que a gente tinha no
peito
a gente já pôde aprender muita coisa com
um militar foco patriotismo trabalho em
equipe mas a gente extrair a importância
da patente
a gente ainda acreditou que maquiavel
estava certo quando disse que era melhor
o chefe temido do que ser amado ea gente
tem que reaprender o conceito de
liderança ea gente teve que olhar para a
liderança diz associada da hierarquia e
entender que liderança é um exercício
feito diariamente que todos vocês e eu
nós lideramos para o bem e para o mal o
tempo inteiro a liderança passa por
alguns conceitos eu infelizmente não
tenho tempo para aprofundar todos eles
mas o primeiro exercício da confiança a
gente é pago programado para não confiar
nas pessoas
a gente estava câmeras para gerenciar o
que fazem na nossa casa com os nossos
filhos
a gente não vive na era de bater ponto
nas organizações não é uma crítica é uma
constatação que a gente é preparado para
não confiar
a gente incentiva muito pouco que a
gente tem medo de supervalorizar as
pessoas a gente não joga muita luz sobre
o caminho de ninguém porque se a gente
iluminar demais aquela pessoa parece
mais do que a gente
a gente perdeu a capacidade de conversar
meu pai foi um grande exemplo dessa
história de conversa porque como todo
jovem eu tinha uma pressa absurda para
saber sobre as coisas só que na época
não tinha um pai universal o google
então tinha que perguntar pro meu pai e
toda vez que eu queria ter alguma
informação com ele e passear com o pai
enquanto aí como é que ela eu vou falar
nomes senhor como é que ela ele falava
meu filho se com essa pressa não vou
falar com você senta aqui pra começar a
copa e não tem esse tempo e vem eu
ficava louco até que um dia ele foi o
primeiro fixou cento o que significa
conversar não pai
acho que sei a história então conversar
é essa parte do princípio que vai
disputar na mesma proporção que você vai
falar mais disso você não pode conversar
com alguém se preocupando com a mensagem
está morta não pode conversar e
estabelecer uma conversa com alguém
torcendo para que aquele momento a
última vez que vocês conversaram com
alguém sem estar preocupado com o número
de votos ap que estava entrando pra mim
né pra solicitar em vocês
a gente admira muito pouco uma pesquisa
de uma grande publicação diz que 98% dos
brasileiros têm medo da inveja de se
sentirem invejados não contam tanto seu
sucesso mas essa mesma pesquisa
2 por cento deles disseram que nunca
sentiu inveja né então engraçado que a
gente tem medo da inveja mas a gente não
inveja ninguém a gente não agradece a
gente reclama a gente lembra de quem fez
mal a gente mas a gente não lembra de
alguém fez alguma coisa incrível pela
gente na última semana quando a gente vê
dos macaquinhos um colchão das costas do
outro a gente fala que lindo como eu
queria ser assim
a única diferença que a gente tem para
os animais a capacidade de colocar
sentimento as relações ea gente tira
todos os dias se sente menos a gente
deixou de dar o braço a gente deixou de
dar beijo a gente deixou de escutar as
pessoas
a gente não se preparar não prepara os
outros a gente viu um show de
empresários ainda não vou treinar a
equipe o tornou era muito alto
se o funcionário vai ficar pouco tempo
na equipe que vai ficar uma semana
trabalhando comigo aquela semana tem que
ser melhor semana da vida dele e se
aquela semana foi a melhor semana da
vida dele vai trazer resultados
incríveis para uma empresa de montar o
prefeito de nova york na época o maior
bumbum
se ele se deveriam ter medo do atentado
de novo atentado terrorista
lógico que a gente deve ter medo o
problema é que a gente faz com medo a
gente se preparar melhor o medo cumpriu
a sua missão
a tolerância que está super em alta tem
um capítulo do meu novo livro dedicado à
tolerância para a gente falar de
liderança não se aprofunda tanto na
tolerância
basicamente o princípio da tolerância
disse pra gente que a gente aprende
muito mais ninguém pensa diferente do
que quem pensa igual é uma delícia
conviver com pessoas que têm o mesmo
tipo de futebol que volta no mesmo
candidato que os mesmos gostos que a
mesma religião mas a gente aprende muito
pouco porque as pessoas pensam igual
agentes e finalmente o amor é a melhor
definição de amor que tem na minha vida
que diz que a maior capacidade que a
gente tem de fazer alguma coisa por
alguém sem exigir algo em troca será que
o que a gente faz na vida da gente
perguntaram pra maria teresa de calcutá
no fim da vida dela porque ela escolheu
calcutá na índia onde 99,6 da população
não cristã era perseguida pelos hindus
pelo governo até pelos fiéis que eram
procurados depois achavam que era
bruxaria ela tomou cusparada em praça
pública o tempo dela foi incendiado duas
vezes e ela respondeu meu filho acha que
o bem que eu faça para os outros do bem
que eu faço pra mim tem que me fazer bem
eu não posso ser muito
bom caráter ou eu tenho caráter ou não
tem caráter eu não posso ter um cara que
eu admiro porque ele é muito ético né
você tem ética ou você não tem ética o
exercício da liderança atual é a gente
ia trabalhar esses conceitos reto se
retroalimentando e voltar a entender que
o óbvio precisa ser dito
a gente é preparada para superar a quem
veio antes da gente a gente ocupa um
cargo a gente tem que ser melhor do que
quem veio antes a gente é avaliado o
tempo inteiro ea gente esquece de dizer
sobre o óbvio a gente esquece de cuidar
das pessoas que estão próximas a gente a
gente começa a inverter essa lógica
quando a gente faz como bernard disso
que para ele o sucesso pra mim
felicidade é gostar mais do processo do
que o resultado a gente joga tudo para o
resultado
a gente espera o final de semana chegar
a gente não dorme ansioso pelo dia da
apresentação da palestra é porque a
gente está esperando que aconteça a
gente espera que essa grande viagem dito
aumento tem gente que espera até ganhar
na loteria né
bernardinho falou sobre isso eu gosto
mais do processo que o resultado eu
lembro bem de uma época em que o meu pai
foi diagnosticado com câncer é e quando
a gente recebeu o resultado da patologia
do meu pai meu pai tinha um câncer
irreversível onde 100% a literatura
médica dizer que meu pai morrer eu tinha
22 anos estava abrindo minha prima
empresa como sócio rafael que está aqui
a grande paixão da minha vida meu
parceiro de vida de tudo né e eu tinha
da única pessoa que eu podia
compartilhar aquele momento o meu pai
meu pai sempre foi um cara otimista o
meu pai tinha falido quebrado perdido
tudo estava muito ferrado mas ele
continuava a acreditar eu falei cara vou
contar com o meu pai que eu tô abrindo
uma empresa com o meu grande amigo da
família toda obviamente nénão não tinha
dado aquele apoio que eu recebi essa
notícia que meu pai tinha 60 dias de
vida naquele momento no com médico e
minhas duas irmãs
a gente tinha duas opções ou agente
enterrado o pai porque a gente sabe que
ele morrer 100% a literatura médica
disse pra gente que a gente tinha com
seu conhecido o resultado não tinha como
dar resultado
a única coisa que sobrava pra gente é o
processo ea gente podia ter um outro
caminho que era transformar aquele 60
dias que o médico deu pra gente os mais
incríveis nas nossas vidas a gente deu
as mãos e minhas irmãs
paramos chorar depois do
- de choro ea gente decidiu que a gente
é transformar aquele 60 dias melhores
das nossas vidas para transformar um
processo complexo dolorido como bruno
falou aqui né
é complicado em que a maioria das
pessoas diz que é impossível ser re
significar você precisa ter um propósito
propósito que a palavra da moda como
todo mundo diz alguma coisa que de forma
proposital impositiva arbitrária e
autoritária você transforma em valor
para sua vida é tão proposital tão
arbitrário que a maioria das pessoas que
estão à sua volta acho que você tá
maluco que saem fora vão embora
nosso propósito é transformar aquele 60
dias mais incríveis nas nossas vidas e
foram ea gente definiu
num dia como a gente mudar aquele
processo quando a gente entrou no
hospital no primeiro dia sábado fazer
uma bateria de exames
a gente viu que tinham mais de 40
pessoas esperando a gente no hospital a
família os amigos e se tinham aquele
número de pessoas por causa do meu pai
tinha amor se tinha amor a gente tinha
que comemorar ea gente decidiu que a
gente comemorar todas as internações do
papai com festa e não era uma festa
qualquer uma grande festa pai foi
internado 30 vezes foram 22
procedimentos realizados no hospital
cinco cômodos todos com festa
meu pai num dos cômodos foi os médicos
falaram que ele não tinha como sair meu
pai saiu voltou pra casa e meu pai no
dia 27 setembro de 2004 a 14 anos atrás
o meu pai acordou deu parabéns pra minha
mãe morreu eu pai morreu oito horas da
manhã do dia do aniversário da mãe desse
mesmo ano de noites aqui que a gente fez
uma baita de uma festa
eu escolhi o dia 27 setembro para lançar
meu livro esse ano meu segundo livro
líderes uma grande festa surpresa para a
mãe na livraria porque o dia 27 além do
aniversário da mãe é o dia que a gente
aprendeu que o processo é mais
importante do que o resultado o renato
mudou a vida dele uma segunda feira a
gente joga nossas segundas feiras fora a
gente tem 52 segundas-feiras no ano
renato mudou a vida dele numa segunda
feira
mesmo tendo transformado em 60 dias com
o pai incríveis não tem um dia que eu
não sinta saudade do meu pai
o médico deu pra gente mais ou menos de
vida o número de segunda-feira que a
gente tem por ano 52 não tem direito a
jogar fora uma segunda feira da vida de
vocês nenhuma terça nenhuma quarta um
dia que você acorda com propósito da sua
vida de alguém você mude
direto pra gente fazer isso é fé pra
quem não gosta de falar de fé porque
acha que tem a ver com religião
substitui por intuição intuição oferta
capacidade que a gente tem de esperar a
gente vive num mundo onde a gente vive
na era do whatsapp a gente no ataque a
gente não tem capacidade de esperar a
gente está no mundo em que a gente
confunde informação com o conhecimento a
gente achou que a gente tem muita
informação e pior a gente achou que
fazer caridade filantropia do ao que a
gente tinha de sobra do que a gente tem
de sobra obrigação filantropia é doar o
que a gente não tem o que todos vocês
gostariam de ter mais na vida de vocês
um dia de vocês tempo a maior de todas
as qualidades que a gente pode fazer do
nosso tempo para entender o outro
exercício de liderança é o tempo que a
gente doa para entender que o nosso
mundo não é referência de mundo que a
gente precisa voltar a gostar de gente
obrigado gente avaliou o delegado
[Aplausos]